Speaker 1: Hey, David, is critical race theory
actually dangerous like right wingers say,
or is it just kind of reductive?
Yeah, this is good.
You know, the I've issued many critiques about
critical race theory on this show.
I don't think it's dangerous.
I think as a general concept, one can always
argue being uninformed can have negative consequences.
And so you could say, well, if you believe
that no matter how fast you drive, you won't
get hurt if you get into a car crash.
Yeah, that's a belief that's dangerous in
a very specific and tangible way.
When it comes to critical race theory.
I wouldn't apply the word dangerous.
I, I do think, however, that critical race
theory could potentially be harmful to race
relations between individuals.
That's number one.
I do think critical race theory is.
Reductive in the way that it deals with race
over many other factors that affect how people
relate to each other in modern society, and
I've talked before about how, you know, critical
theories like critical race theory heavily
are supported by ideas of postmodernism and
post structuralism.
And this is not me going all Jordan Peterson
talking about postmodernism.
And that's not it's not this vague critique.
And I'm not saying anything beyond what I'm
actually saying, but the basis of critical
race theory and the genesis of some of the
ideology and postmodernism and post structuralism
relies on the ideas in some combination that
reality is socially constructed.
It's sort of an attack on empiricism and it's
a propping up of the idea that any reality,
any notion, any analysis could be just as
real as any other and in some cases taken
to a very extreme place, could be deserves
equal footing in discussions about how society
should be organized.
And then one of the other aspects of critical
race theory that I think is very problematic
now.
But by the way, if you're going to email me,
you're going to say, David, that one piece
doesn't apply to all of critical race theory.
Fine.
I'm talking in generalities about things that
exist within enclaves of critical race theory.
One of the really concerning things I see
are very, very casual claims levied against
anyone who challenges aspects of critical
race theory that merely by challenging critical
race theory, you are a white supremacist,
you are racist, you are an oppressor.
You are part of the problem.
We saw this earlier this week with the story
about the Seattle Pride event, some pride
event in Seattle that was only going to charge
a fee to white people.
How do you identify which those people are?
I don't know.
And they weren't calling it an admission fee.
They were calling it a reparations fee to
get around, saying the admission is is depending
on race.
And then when some members of the Seattle
City Council said this, this is bad, this
really doesn't make any sense.
They were accused of doing violence by critiquing
the plan of only charging the reparations
fee to the white attendees.
That's a that's a nonstarter for me.
That's the opposite of rational inquiry.
And so back to the question, is critical race
theory actually dangerous?
I think just about any idea if taken far enough,
you could justify and say it would be dangerous
in this way?
I think that it's incomplete.
I think it's reductive.
And I think it's counterproductive over the
long term to both race relations and achieving
real equality under the law and and in society,
which I think is an important add on, because
many areas we have equality under the law,
but for socio cultural reasons, we don't have
actual equality.
That's my sense.
Let me know your thoughts